[Music]
oh hey porch hey how are you porch okay
listen I know this looks bad I know you
think I'm bougie and you're here to take
me to the guillotine well fair enough
but before you do can a dying Queen make
one request how about this
I'm minutia Harris on so you can cut my
head off but first you have to let me
tell you my life story fair that's super
[ __ ] great now sit on [ __ ] and allow
me to explain myself I'll start at the
beginning my earliest memories are of
aesthetic bliss I was raised in a suburb
of Washington DC where the most exciting
attraction for children is the National
Museum of Natural History
at least it's the most exciting
attraction for nerdy children who might
I add deserve their abuse at the hands
of dumber cooler children kids usually
gather around the fossils and don't get
me wrong I liked a good Stegosaurus as
much as the next five-year-old but my
real passion was the Gem and Mineral
haul ah the sparkle and shimmer it
inspired me to start my own little gem
collection
I had amethyst quartz obsidian Jade the
little pressure of each stone was almost
enough to make up for my sixth grade
teacher mrs. Romano forcing me to pee my
pants in public
[ __ ] you Romano I'm glad your father
died comrades losers and haters I would
like to propose that aesthetic
sensibility whether for gemstones
architecture fashion or music begins
with absolute pleasure you rotate the
crystal in your hand and are dazzled by
the sparkle and the light your nape hair
stands on end and a tingle goes down
your spine yes God but as you get older
things get more complicated Northern
Virginia is McMansion country and while
my family lived in a more modest
colonial I remember riding around in the
back of the minivan looking at some
stylistically jumbled monstrosities and
I would get excited by some little
detail like
a circle of fake battlements atop a
misplaced tower but then my mom would
say look at this ostentatious trash so
you learn you learn taste according to
the social class of your upbringing and
with taste comes all this adult baggage
snobbery and pretense and conceit so I
don't know what you've heard from my
accusers but I assure you I have nothing
to do with taste I am but a simple queen
longing for the pleasure of my childhood
gem so stripy sock cat girls of the heck
and Revolutionary Committee before you
pass sentence allow me to make my case
Gorge
[Music]
the
what success oh hey how are you cords
look Alex stuff I like shiny things from
either really is still a simple
childlike pleasure to it all but the
adult reality is opulence is more than
just shimmer and sparkle there's a
social context for it it generally means
something why does Donald Trump's
apartment look like Liberace married a
Turkmenistan II dictator and moved into
a Cheesecake Factory well because he's
trying to send a message maybe to the
world maybe to himself he's saying
behold I am a winner a very stable
genius with one of the highest IQs
powerful people have often used opulence
to symbolize their power from the
Pharaohs of Egypt to the kings of France
to even the humble servants of the
world's major religions I guess it's
been called like shiny things too in
America opulence more specifically means
not just power but success it is the
trophy by which you show the world that
you achieved the American dream the plot
line of our central cultural myth is the
story of rags to riches and the words of
drake started from the bottom now we're
here started from the bottom now the
whole team spiky hair opulence is the
aesthetic display that you're here
you've made it your rich bed remember in
high school when you had to read The
Great Gatsby by f scott sparknotes the
character Jay Gatsby doesn't even like
opulent mansion parties but he throws
them anyway just to show his crush Daisy
that he's made it that he's a success
but he's worth something and as we all
remember in the end they get married and
defeat the monster Grendel to save the
whole of her off-guard at least that's
what I wrote in my 10th grade English
essay about how the theme of the Great
Gatsby is money always leads to
happiness I've got a d-minus
I like dollars I like diamonds I like
money
I like shining I like those
Lancey yoga's bak I'm sure cardi B
really does like diamonds and red
bottoms and driving lambs and all that
[ __ ] but teacher picked me picked me
let's talk about symbols let's talk
about allegory let's talk about metaphor
let's talk about themes fellow students
let us place the texts in historical
context everyone knows that cardi B went
from being a teenage stripper to making
money moves that's the American dream
hip-hop opulence isn't just gratuitous
glitz and hedonism it's a celebration of
success for people who often come from
backgrounds where that kind of success
is really improbable don't you think
it's kind of weird that conservatives
still say react musically nor the
problems with the blacks for
conservatives the American Dream is
supposed to be the solution to poverty
and is there any sector of our culture
where the American Dream is more on
ironically celebrated than hip-hop it's
not just hip-hop though flaunted wealth
is pretty inescapable throughout pop
culture you can't even turn on the radio
without hearing about the Gucci and the
Ferraris and the Fendi love of God is in
the Omani in the Maseratis our entire
culture has been replaced by a parade of
overpriced Italian [ __ ] which to be
clear I'm completely in favor of burned
down the Statue of Liberty for all I
[ __ ] care and replace it with a
large-scale figure of Donatella Versace
holding a bottle of Cristal that's at
least a more honest representation of
our culture than the hypocritical cheese
furs currently inscribed on Liberty
Island
I guess crystals French isn't it well no
one really drinks Italian booze we we
have standards in this country listen up
America we live in a society a society
of champagne wishes and caviar dreams
not of climbers but of graspers to
paraphrase Ian Danskin maybe anyone can
achieve the American
but everyone cannot and the fact of the
matter is most people don't I mean what
would it even mean to be rich unless
someone else was poor I mean who's gonna
polish your golden toilet not on the
rich people that's for sure so when you
live in a society that constantly
equates wealth and success but which is
also so unequal that most people will
never be wealthy well what's the average
person supposed to do to fantasy I wish
the world were my gem collection I wish
I owned everything I'm really just the
worst kind of Philistine you know I go
to an art museum and it's like Monet
Rembrandt
okay that's super [ __ ] great but can
i buy it well no I can't buy it the grim
reality is you can't own everything so
what do you do well you fake it you
create an illusion
I don't own this building now you boob
off the streets of Baltimore can walk in
here as indeed you did that's okay I
need a witness I need you to see me here
among the other art where I'm being seen
that way it makes me feel good you know
makes me feel valuable you know you
don't actually need wealth to be opulent
because opulence
is not abundance opulence is the
aesthetic of abundance it is the
aesthetic of owning everything
the phrase opulence you own everything
is at this point basically a gay
internet meme
but it originally comes from the
documentary Paris is burning up at the
Harlem ballroom culture in the 1980s
words proclaimed by MC junior labeija
[Music]
it's not a celebration of a real
lifestyle of luxury and decadence in
fact as pepper labeija says of the queer
black and latin-american participants of
the Bulls you know a lot of those kids
and boys they don't have to of nothing
some of them don't even eat so ballroom
opulence is a fantasy of wealth and
glamour an illusion created by skillful
artifice participants walk categories
like executive realness
with the goal of being indistinguishable
from a real executive nowadays every
white queer says the word realness I got
some kind of a frivolous way I mean
whose tamang us honestly hasn't slipped
into a dissociative fugue state dressed
up as a clown kidnapped a few
neighborhood children and told the cops
I'm giving you John Wayne Gacy realness
hunty I did it officer I did the
cultural appropriation I am a colonizer
I am part of the problem and I'm sorry
take me away boys that's crazy that's
mega coconuts I guess I should explain
that American slang works according to
what we might call a trickle up model of
linguistics all the new words are
invented by the most marginalized gay
and trans people of color then those
words trickle up to straight black
people and white gays and then finally
white sis hats start using them a lot of
times the original meaning or context
gets lost along the way so originally
realness as Shawn fate put it was not
just a sassy by word for a convincing
costume but a tragic comic disguise of
the chasm between what is being emulated
and what is absent namely racial justice
Casa quality and safety realness in that
sense is a much more complicated and
interesting concept than the generic
trans notion of passing passing is just
looking like a 5-2 happy baby bouncy bio
girl whereas in the ballroom sense
realness has a subtext of defying
injustice you're using artifice to
create the illusion of a lifestyle
that has been unjustly kept beyond your
reach you're not really an executive but
you're looking like the executive and
therefore you're storing the straight
world that I can be an executive if I
had the opportunity I could be able
because I can look like I think one
reason there's been a surge of interest
in eighties ballroom culture such as the
FX drama pose which is said during the
era is that it dramatizes an essential
truth about America it's really
important to people in this country to
at least sometimes feel like they're
living a luxe life even if in fact they
aren't Las Vegas is essentially an
entire city that exploits that need
Vegas hotels like the Venetian the
Bellagio and Caesars Palace are designed
to make you feel like a fancy [ __ ] even
though they're actually just high-rise
traps designed to lure you in and take
your money and if there's one thing I
can't stand it's try but the trap works
because part of what it is to be
American is to want to feel like a fancy
[ __ ] I actually love Vegas I was there
last year for the only good YouTube for
Lindsay Ellis's bachelorette party I
felt like a fancy [ __ ] and I wasn't
tempted to gamble but when I was younger
I don't when I was in my mid 40s I did
once experienced the first exciting
stages of a gambling habit I happened to
go to the casino once out of curiosity
and had some good luck playing blackjack
I mean I wasn't a high roller or
anything but my first time I walked out
with an extra $200 and that was a lot of
money to me at the time I was working a
customer service job making $10 an hour
so to make $200 in five minutes that's
worth 20 hours of soul-crushing customer
service toil before taxes so I went back
and I went back but I never got lucky
again and fortunately that was enough to
discourage me I remember one time as I
was leaving the casino I saw this man
standing outside with this look on his
face that I have never seen on a human
being before or Suns just absolute shock
despair this deep shame and self-disgust
the kind of face that says I'm gonna
have to explain to my wife
I spent the kids college savings on a
high limit slot machine and there is
nothing opulent about that north of
people at the slots and wheelchairs with
IV drips trying to pay off their
hospital bills America we are a bad
country
Donald Trump is a Vegas man he's pulling
this grift on the entire country and it
keeps working because the fantasy
opulence of the American dream is more
enchanting to the imagination than any
abstract mathematics of economic
equality so it may seem like Americans
are all under the same spell but in fact
there are two very different types of
magic at work for the wealthy and
powerful opulence is a flex a
demonstration of their wealth and power
but for the marginalized and
impoverished opulence is a simulacrum of
the wealth and power they've been denied
the aesthetic might be similar but in
terms of function it's like the
difference between a viper and a
butterfly serving viper realness
three-class hey how are you hey how are
you hey how are you hey how are you
people don't understand how difficult it
is to be this blond you know a
biological female that looks like me I'm
afraid some transvestite psycho is gonna
sneak in through a rear window and I'll
have to dial M for murder I get vertigo
just thinking about it
I've always found the Marxist analysis
of class difficult to apply to the
present day
as a typical modern woman it's just
super [ __ ] hard for me to relate to
this and I hope and I hope and I hope
that's process like Boosh mozzie and
proletarian hoops - is she where's her
summer collection that's super [ __ ]
greement can I buy it Marx's typical
examples are a factory owner in a
factory worker no I could be out of
touch but personally I've never met a
factory worker or a factory owner for
that matter they must all be on a brand
trip to China working on the BMPs on her
collection was
supposed to distinguish the booties from
the proles is that the bougie zone the
means of production and the proles
worked for wages but what about a
bartender who owns the bar she works and
what about youtubers which side of the
revolution are we on I'm just trying to
figure out where I stand here because if
the revolution starts on Twitter my head
is definitely going in the basket and
then I'll have no choice but to do the
conservative talk show circuit you know
like most people whose brains are
detached from their bodies Marie
Antoinette did nothing wrong in our yo I
feel like a class analysis with only two
classes must be overly simplistic my
favorite book about class in America is
Paul Fussell's class a guide through the
American status system which describes
nine distinct classes Fussel is not as
concerned with economic relations
between classes as he is with status
when Marxist sometimes call social and
cultural capital things like education
style taste an attitude towards money
now the book was published in 1983 so a
lot of the references and details are
out of date but there's an eerie
familiarity to a lot of the core
observations and it's also just pretty
funny like his quasi scientific
observation that the higher your social
class the smaller the balls and the
sports you play or his description of
middle-class living rooms your real
middle class refuses to show any but the
most bland books and magazines on its
coffee tables otherwise expressions of
opinion awkward questions are even ideas
might result what I've Fussell's core
themes is that it's not how much money
you have that defines your class so much
is how you got your money if you had to
work for your money then you're not
really upper class the upper class has
inherited wealth and as a result they're
very confident they don't feel the need
to prove themselves likewise the lower
classes have basically accepted their
position on the ladder but then there's
the middle class who are social climbers
and who compensate for their
insecurities by for example placing a
pretentious collage of university bumper
stickers in the back of the family car
this is
meaning of the Lord Melbourne quote the
higher and lower crosses there's some
good in them but the middle classes are
all affectation and conceit and pretend
some concealment now opulent aesthetics
are typically cultivated by people with
something to prove whether its
marginalized ballroom performers proving
their worth to themselves or the new
rich building McMansions to show off
their wealth to others so there's
something kind of odd about Donald Trump
he inherited his wealth so he should
know better than to have golden faucets
but he doesn't as Fran Lebowitz said
he's a poor person's idea of a rich
person and that's actually his charm
it's part of his mass appeal Trump
behaves like a pro who won the lottery
so there's actually something kind of
relatable on snobbish and even pseudo
democratic about the golden faucets
people who have wealth but not class are
actually very popular in this country we
don't like class here because class is
exclusionary whereas anyone can acquire
wealth we tell ourselves so wealth feels
potentially inclusive of everyone even
though in practice it isn't now the
upper-class cultural elite in this
country the real classy people are
mostly very unlike Trump instead of
being ostentatious and gaudy they
embrace the reserved old money values of
aristocratic wasps white anglo-saxon
Protestants Fussel notes for instance
that they tend to value privacy over
showing off they like to live at the end
of long driveways and houses away from
public view they dressed down while
traveling so as to avoid drawing
attention to themselves these are
essentially survival skills of the
experienced rich if you flaunt your
wealth too much people might rob you or
they might get benefits and come after
you with pitchforks and guillotines or
worse taxation old money knows this but
new money just cannot resist the
temptation to show off I actually wonder
if the old waspy upper class is dying
out
I feel like Donald Trump represents a
victory of money over class his
presidency validates the idea that you
can be as vulgar as you want so long as
you have the cash to back it up so the
old class system is dying
and in its place we have universally
adopted the mindset of the nouveau riche
if you got it flaunt it
if you haven't got it find a way to
flaunt it anyway now I'm sure this is
all very tragic and disappointing to
people of class and taste but to a tacky
transsexual rhinestone connoisseur it's
actually fantastic news for taste
listen comrades I've been pretty down on
opulence so far and I could continue
analyzing it in terms of inequality and
class struggle but you already know all
that that's why you came to cut my head
off but hold on is that really all there
is to esthetics Marxist economic
analysis or the SJW version that makes
everything about race and gender as the
most notorious art critic of the 21st
century once said but remember that it's
both possible and even necessary to
simultaneously enjoy media while also
being critical of it's more problematic
or pernicious aspects so what about the
enjoyment part surely you wouldn't be
had a queen just for liking a shiny
thing is there no room for art for art's
sake the great philosopher and venerable
German closet Queen Froylan Immanuel
Hildegard Marlena Kennedy Davenport [ __ ]
so that pure aesthetic taste is
disinterested that is completely free of
any material desire of course miss thing
also founded the hashtag no fab movement
so I don't know how seriously we want to
take of that it's actually kind of
similar to what Plato said about
aesthetic sense that it merely begins
with a desire for the bodies of
beautiful boys which is really just a
shadow of our true longing for the
concept of beauty itself God the entire
history of Western aesthetic philosophy
is just a bunch of repressed homos
trying to rationalize away their debates
perversions what must that be like from
the bottom of my [ __ ] and my
father [ __ ] heart that must be super
[ __ ] hard for them I can't even a
matte I mean it makes sense really
straight men don't have these problems
they got away with painting softcore for
500 years and never had to think about
it I guess Nietzsche's the exception he
was straight and a philosopher but he
was an in cell and let's be honest
definitely a true chaser
the only upstanding aesthetician in all
of Western history is the respectable
English gentleman Oscar Wilde
according to Wilde those who find ugly
me
beautiful things are corrupt without
being charming this is a fault those who
find beautiful meanings and beautiful
things are the cultivated for these
there is hope
they are the elect to whom beautiful
things mean only beauty
spoken like a poet you want to be
cultivated don't you don't you think I'm
beautiful look I'll play it your way
let's swing back to the other side of
the sarkeesian pendulum here a
sentimental as I personally am about art
for art's sake and all that from a
strictly a sociological perspective I
have to admit taste is pretty intimately
related to power when you go to a museum
you look at various objects on pedestals
under special lighting that makes them
appear magical now that's also what you
do at Bed Bath and Beyond but the
difference is that at the Museum you
can't buy anything and that turns out to
be important for contine reasons and the
retail context of commodity fetishism
you correlate your aesthetic taste with
material desire whereas in the museum's
because you can't buy anything you feel
that your aesthetic pleasure is pure
that you're simply enjoying out of
context objects but of course that's an
illusion the museum is the context and
the context is telling you that the
things you're looking at or art so
whoever decides what's in the museum
decides what good taste is what's
beautiful what's valuable think about
the music video for apeshit by the
carters the AUSA and jay-z pose in
various places in the Louvre conferring
upon themselves the status in the
cultural grandeur of the art but it's
not just a flux it means something more
than that because of the racial
disparity between the performers and the
setting black people and black art are
mostly excluded from museums like the
Louvre so seeing J&B they're looking so
regal with black dancers even
overshadowing canonical European art
it's like a full moment a lot of people
have a deep longing for the sensitive
dignity and grandeur conferred by
classical
that's why transwoman love that picture
someone photoshopped of the Three Graces
but with dicks
I'll admit that silly picture actually
had an emotional effect on me because
here in the West it's actually hard to
think of your body type as beautiful
until you've seen it sculpted in white
marble oh speaking of which white marble
is a lie for most of art history history
scholars have insisted that the iconic
ghostly whiteness of classical statues
was the distinguishing feature of
Western sculpture proof of the elegant
taste of the ancient Greeks and Romans
in reality of course it turns out they
were painted the colors of something a
drag queen might wear to a quinceanera
scholars had been noticing paint
remnants on these statues for hundreds
of years but were totally in denial
about it because the pure whiteness of
these figures was like a sacred dogma
Margaret Talbot in The New Yorker
attributes the dogma in part to a
tendency to equate whiteness with beauty
taste and classical ideals anti-sikh
color as alien sensual and garish in
Fabio berry an art historian who is now
at Stanford complained that a boldly
colored re-creation of a statue of the
Emperor Augustus at the Vatican Museum
looked like a crossdresser trying to
hail a taxi hey how are you and you just
know that when the news first broke some
horrified wasp classicists turned to a
colleague and said Oh
Kingsley it looks it looks Mexican in
fact for the crime of writing about
paint on statues some art historians
have been harassed by the all right who
don't take kindly to anyone questioning
their white supremacist myths about
antiquity there's some pretty insidious
identitarian prejudices here hiding out
under the cloak of taste good taste for
upper and middle cause white people
generally includes a reflexive disdain
for anything a little bit too colorful
it's these classes that constantly use
the words gaudy
garish tawdry tacky Joe Weldon author
fears the history of leopard-print
observed that tacky as a concept refers
to the lack of cultivation or the
resistance to taste and more often than
not refers to tastes that are not
suitably conservative furthermore tacky
is likely to be feminine ethnic queer
deviant not manly not practical not
businesslike not serious aesthetic
excess particularly of colors patterns
and bling is especially offensive to
conservative wasp taste tacky is often
where the imagination runs free where
the heart is where the soul is and where
the fun is
well that's good news because people
call my aesthetic tacky all the time I
can't imagine why we just got some more
jewels on my - or camp
people call me camp and sometimes they
don't know if I'm being praised or
insulted I suppose it depends on what
camp means camp was the theme of this
year's Met Gala and my feed was flooded
with Brooklynite intellectuals competing
to outwit each other with the most
erudite definition of what camp really
is what I gather is there's a couple
competing definitions the first I'll
call coward camp this bratty hipster
notion of having bad taste on purpose I
have no respect for this whatsoever this
is nothing but an anxious and defensive
refusal to take a risk you think you're
safe from criticism because your look is
bad on purpose sock thought take a stand
you [ __ ] [ __ ] I take a great offense
to this as a person whose look is about
on accident and Susan Sontag agrees with
me in notes on Camp she distinguishes
between naive and deliberate camp your
camp is always naive camp which knows
itself to be camp or camping is usually
less satisfying some tag defines naive
camp has failed seriousness a grand
artistic vision that gets a little out
of control and enters into absurd
territory hey how are yo I don't know my
philosophy of style is that people
should wear what looks good to them
I was joking earlier when I said my look
is bad on accident I think my aesthetic
is good this is what looks good to me
well I'm aware other people might judge
it by liquid John water is sad about
there being good bad taste and bad bad
taste one must remember there is such a
thing as good bad taste and bad bad
taste to understand bad taste one must
have very good taste I've wondered for a
long time why I'm so attracted to bad
taste like I technically have the
education to know better I know about
Glenn Gould but I prefer the barrace why
am I so tacky I think it's because I'm a
transsexual which lowers you at least a
class if you were born upper-class and
you're transsexual you're middle class
and I'll [ __ ] if you were born middle
class in your transsexual you are now
lower class and if you were born lower
class and they're transsexual Oh
Sawadee you'd better start a revolution
Marsha P Johnson hi how are you chicks
with bread 5 glamour trance women have a
special relationship with glamour at
least those of us who came of age in the
1960s and the most basic everyday sense
glam is a way of styling yourself it's
luxurious hair it's high drama makeup
it's long nails it's a glitter
everywhere
it's opposing like a fashion model but
originally the word glamour comes from
the Scottish word grammar II meaning
magic or enchantment and glamour still
involves a kind of illusion or charm
cast on a spectator the connection
between glamour and opulence is explored
in the 2008 for us a diva mclamb is
transgenderism a critique of or
capitulation to opulence driven glamour
models by transgender writer in
underground house music producer Terry
templates aka DJ sprinkles sprinkles
rides Europe's ruling elite used
opulence as an ideological weapon to
befuddle the lower classes with glimpses
of heaven on earth our lifestyles so
foreign and unattainable that it could
only be the result of divination it is
this spell of opulence that led to our
current definition of glamour which is
more associated with wealth
magic sprinkles alludes to an earlier
form of glamour or Granberry that was
associated with witchcraft paganism and
sexual deviancy but in our capitalist
society glamour is a spell of opulence
conjuring up what is often a fantasy of
a lavish life for example a lot of dry
Queens practice this sort of illusionism
by impersonating celebrities thereby
acquiring the glamour of actresses pop
stars and models a secondhand sprinkles
is bothered by the way this sort of
secondhand glamour acquires its power
from unquestioned social hierarchies
glamour is suspect as a critical minded
political forum because it is about
social distance not social integration
the promise of the pop diva is not the
promise of social transformation but
individual transformation in which the
exploited becomes the exploiter it is
the promise of an individual's class
mobility not social betterment or class
critique it is by and large the American
Dream now I have to admit this is a
version of the American Dream that hits
pretty close to home for me the
overarching plot line of my whole entire
YouTube gender journey is that I used to
be a tragic mess and I'm still a tragic
mess but when I started this channel I
was a broke gender dysphoria alcoholic
cross-dressing tragic mass I'd play a
clip but honestly those videos are still
too painful for me to even glance' and
now I mean look at me look how far I've
come I look like a moderately talented
female impersonator hey how are you
those first several months of transition
though they were rough I had a lot of
trouble in the beginning I had to get
laughed out of restaurants and I was so
proud that I wouldn't let anyone see how
much that stuff hurt me
I would say well [ __ ] them I know I'm
great and then I'd go cry my eyes out
alone in my car and I was a youtuber
that whole time too which I mean the
cyberbullying alone I don't think you
can even imagine the extent of it if you
haven't been in that situation you know
hundreds of strangers dissecting your
voice picking apart your face and body
clocking your clothes and makeup digging
up your past trying to deduce the nature
of your sexual pathology from the shape
of your skull a lot of that a lot of its
hilarious to me now but there was a time
when it caused a lot of pain but that
pain spurred me to work on my glow up
like it was the cure for cancer like my
life depended on it which is basically
how it felt
now sometimes my transcritical eyes meet
us as one tweeter put it cripplingly
obsessed with passing and passing and
day-to-day life was always a goal for me
but glam to me is not about passing I
think I actually passed better in no
makeup than I do an eye shadow out to
here you know assists woman can wear eye
shadow out to here and people think
she's just really into makeup or
Instagram or cosplay or something but
when I do it I think it looks like drag
which serves to call more attention to
my situation but on YouTube I mean
clearly I don't try to pass as a normal
woman everyone here knows I'm trans
anyway so what's the point I would
describe this presentation as female
impersonator and that's basically what I
am a female female impersonator and I
present this way because it's fun I find
it artistically fulfilling and let's be
honest there's a part of me that always
wanted to be that kind of
larger-than-life
super woman but I'm also creating
special effects for the camera a
sprinkle says drama offers a strange
over performance of gender signifiers a
tenuously woven layer of super
femininity which is so distracting that
it successfully hides the transgendered
body beneath now a lot of leftists trans
people have grown disillusioned with the
individual class mobile
be represented by glamour as well as by
transition glow-up narratives and I
think that disillusionment in a growing
revolutionary sentiment or at the heart
of this intensive anger and resentment
I've noticed a lot of trans women have
for drag queens for glamorous trans
Instagram models and let's be honest for
me
here's sprinkles one more time as long
as an MTF public acceptance is gauged by
her ability to emulate glamorous body
and style requirements that elude most
quote real women then I'll have to ask
you to pardon this transgendered writer
phone are feeling represented by RuPaul
any more than my mother feels
represented by Marilyn Monroe or
princess time a lot of trans women are
basically fed up with having to serve
the world a fantasy all the time they
want to be seen for who they are without
doing any of that [ __ ] they're fed up
with glamour they're set up with
realness they're fed up with RuPaul and
a lot of them are pretty fed up with me
and I you've been i you've been i you
6mv
the marxist art critic John Berger
called glamour the happiness of being
envied being envied is a solitary form
of reassurance
it depends precisely upon or not sharing
your experiences with those who envy you
but being interviewed as a form of
happiness only in the imagination the
actual experience of being unbeatable
socks this is the risk of opulence it
invites not just enchanted admiration
but also an theme and where envy goes if
a guillotine follows for at least a
vindictive taxation this is why the
experience rich new to tone down the
opulence build a nice high wall around
their properties and make a lot of
high-profile charitable donations we can
call this kind of strategizing the
public relations of success it certainly
helps a barracks to riches story
especially if you can make other people
feel included in some way
success that's part of the appeal of
hip-hop opulence is that it seems to
elevate not just a single performer but
an entire underclass
conversely being perceived as
exclusionary elitist or snobbish is
gonna cost you big in terms of envy
management YouTube music critic taught
in the shadows did a review of ariana
grande's song seven rings in which he
basically drags ariana who apparently is
white for appropriating a bunch of
hip-hop rights to rigid signifiers
without any of the subtext of starting
from the bottom she's not showcasing a
triumph over adversity she's just a
white girl who likes stuff we started
from the bottom now the whole team
[ __ ] here so in Todd's words the song
is a grotesque bullying of VIP only
privileged flex of a mean girl shoving
her wealth in your face I actually like
that song but I'm into that sort of
thing believe me Mommy Oh
fellow students as a case study in the
public relations of success and envy
management let us compare and contrast
two successful youtubers Jeffrey star
and Gigi gorgeous there's enough
similarities between them for the
differences to be interesting to both
LGB and orti they're both white
they're both blonde sometimes they're
both feminine they're both rich and they
both flaunt their opulent lifestyles the
nonetheless people basically seem to
like jeffrey star whereas GG well i
don't want to say people don't like her
but they don't relate to her the best
example of this is her 2017 video I wear
Walmart for a week with its gasp
inducing life to dislike ratio let's
analyze what went wrong so for today's
video I thought we would take it to a
place I've never been
Walmart so that's a bad start Gorge most
Americans have been to Walmart never
having been marks your upbringing as
upper middle class at least treating
going to Walmart as some kind of
challenge kind of comes across as you
and your rich friends being like what if
we pretend to be poor for a day I wonder
if we're gonna see any people at Walmart
you know that what
babies crying the trauma Gigi no you
need to turn the shame down like it's
like 20 notches Gorge I keep taking my
shin on this cart I'm literally gonna
have bruises and someone remake these
carts please
dangerous they're gonna cut your head
off Gorge
[Music]
what should we get snacks maybe like a
gown for a red carpet do they sell gowns
here
this to me is peek GG strolling down the
aisles of Walmart with a 2-liter bottle
of Mountain Dew that you pull up from
the shelves saying I need something for
a red carpet do they have gowns here
this to me is an iconic fashion moment
this is naive camp this is everything
the idea that she has privileges that
other people don't
has never once crossed her mind and that
is a very special precious thing that I
want to cherish personally I have no
choice but to stay on the youtube
comments section however is not as
amused as I am nor as forgiving this is
a second time I've done a close reading
of a GG video it's getting kind of weird
also why hasn't she answered my letters
step on my throat mommy and let's look
at Jeffrey star Jeffrey did similar
kinds of videos to Gigi he's even done
his own video wearing Walmart for a day
which people loved and my first impulse
when explaining the differences in
public perception it's a scream thanks
is that my and there's maybe a little
like going on I do think a rich woman is
more irritating to people than a rich
man but there's clearly more than that
going on here
Jeffrey's fans are I assume mostly women
and not rich women regular women the
women who work as a dollar store love
them I'm your biggest fan
ordinary people actually enjoy watching
Jeffrey's plot as millions of dollars of
designer bags and clothes because they
either live vicariously through him or
they see him as aspirational it's the
same reason why poor people have always
enjoyed watching reality TV shows about
the extremely wealthy the centerpiece of
Jeffrey stars brand is that he's
self-made he represents himself as
having started from the bottom you know
he talks about his white-trash
upbringing and just generally seems like
he hasn't let his wealth go to his head
a good example of this is his private
jet Burger King Luke bomb now at first
you might think that a private jet is
not very relatable but the Burger King
aspect brings it back down to earth
Jeffery seems like he's been to Burger
King before he's able to order fluently
he's even kind of charming to the
cashier he doesn't
scoff or pinches nose at anything also
the Gucci Bharat wear as Gigi I mean
don't get me wrong I do love Gigi but I
don't know if sis would make it out of
Burger King alive you know she'd commit
some terrible upper-class solecism like
I don't know not understanding the
concept of a value meal
I'm sure Gigi would make an entertaining
video just not a relatable video you
know or she'd somehow contract syphilis
from the toilet seat and do a story talk
about that that's really when Gigi's at
her best she kind of comes back down to
earth whenever she's serving the real
transsexual Housewives of Beverly Hills
needs David Cronenberg so I'm like but I
see this white little Chiclets in my
hand I'm feeling with my tongue and I'm
like oh my god economic inequality in
this country has always been enabled by
the fact that people basically like the
rich
yeah we judge people who live in
McMansions and we get irritated by
elitist out-of-touch behavior but
ultimately we have no choice but to
stand and the people we stand the
hardest are people like Jeffries Starr
who in a way seems like a poor person
who just so happens to be very rich now
if any quality increases enough I
suspect the standing will stop because
it's [ __ ] I watched jeffree star spend
sixty nine thousand dollars in one trip
to the Louie Vuitton store if what
you're doing is fantasizing about what
you would buy with that much money but
if you're thinking about how sixty nine
thousand dollars can pay off your life
groaning medical debt or about how you'd
be able to afford cancer treatments for
your dying wife this kind of thing will
start getting under your skin
and eventually people will start
building guillotines again in fact the
only way I can imagine a revolution
happening in this country is if rich
people start behaving as badly as
possible this isn't your dream job
and this is free right whatever okay
great
seven ruin
[Music]
good evening gorge ever notice how most
vampires are like cows or Queens or
ELISA rich I guess some are edgy biker
teens but I don't associate without
trash
gothic horror really got started as a
genre with 18th and 19th century novels
which were usually set in an old
decaying castle or mansion but the late
19th century the earth stock recei had
lost a lot of its relevance as a class
so aristocratic vampires like Count
Dracula represented a dying world order
and also maybe the metaphorical blood
sucking of cava nur's by the landed
gentry vampires were also usually
seducers and the aristocrats seducer
trope had actually played an important
role in turning public opinion against
the nobility said the gothic aesthetic
is an aesthetic of dead and decaying
opulence and that aesthetic has evolved
over time from the ruins of a medieval
castle to the iconic haunted house which
an American horror is usually a decaying
Victorian mansion
it's a trope with an interesting back
story during the Gilded Age
industrialization produced a new wealthy
class of people who built what were
essentially 19th century McMansions
when the Great Depression hit a lot of
these Victorian mansions were abandoned
and began to decay which gave them
morbid associations that made them
perfect for stories about hauntings and
psychos weirdos some ruined opulence
becomes gothic which kind of makes you
think we live in an age of opulence and
inequality and growing irritation with
abusive men in power the middle class is
shrinking social unrest is on the rise
it seems like a new economic order could
be on the horizon when the opulence of
our age decays will there be a new
gothic aesthetic of ruined shopping
malls well they're kind of already is
the urban explorer Danville is a YouTube
bird known for his dead Maul series in
which he explores the ruins of abandoned
shopping malls for example the now
demolished Owings Mills Mall just north
of Baltimore the mall opened in 1986 as
the Owings Mills
and more champagne Goldust and pink
feathers heralds within a new era for
always metals today's opening of the
Owings Mills fashion law does not only
mean a new high fashion place to shop it
also means lots of new developments and
jobs for Baltimore County it had a
Macy's a Lord and Taylor a Saks Fifth
Avenue it was a big high-end mall but in
1992 a woman who worked as a cleaner at
Saks was murdered during an armed
robbery on the trail between the mall
and the Baltimore metro station after
the murder the mall got a reputation for
being unsafe and slowly the stores
closed down dan recorded two videos at
Owings Mills in 2015 but only five of
the original 155 stores remained he
takes us through this strangely clean
and empty halls the drained fountains
the gutted food court watching these
videos seems to provoke an emotional
response and a lot of people some say
they feel nostalgic or sad some express
rage of the waste and futility some find
it creepy or even horrifying and some
have a dark sense of humor about the
absurdity of it all one commenter says I
think it is still hitting people with
slow motion shock that the 20th century
is really over in the 80s this looked
like the start of a big new world of
wealth for everyone in fact it was the
last gasp of 20th century general
prosperity I agree with all these
comments and I feel every one of these
emotions I think there is a new
aesthetic sensibility emerging here a
gothic aesthetic for the 21st century
this decaying opulence that is the
carcass of twentieth-century consumerism
oh it gives me a chill my nave hair
stands on end and a tingle goes down my
spine
the owings mills mall was totally
demolished in late 2016 and dance final
video about it we see clips from his
earlier Owings Mills videos intercut
with absolutely post-apocalyptic footage
of the half demolished ruin it's not
like the feeling of exploring a ruined
temple or Abbey where you somehow
perceive the spiritual significance in
the original building in a dead mall you
do sense the ghosts of the shoppers and
the workers their aspirations and
material longings but what does the
crumbling wreckage of a JC Penney really
mean that is a question that will haunt
me to the grave alright comrades I've
said my piece I'll come quietly
there's no reason to tie me down I mean
unless you're into that
in which case by all means no I won't
resist I accept my fate
[Music]
[ __ ] you Romano I'm glad your father
died - just get that out there before I
had to say tell us be honest
definitely a chaser god I sure do you
think I'm funny
he wasn't himself and definitely a
chaser okay I wish you'd of what I've
written huh
can't ya but I'm saying his name wrong
to them an [ __ ] I hope you're
enjoying this there and watch me once
modeled my hands like shriek negative
tub food jewels arching leg do you want
to get in here a lot I assume just
getting oil all over my fur great it's
not real for whatever clarify that for
the vegans in the comment section all
moral people I can't stand
people who have some sense of decency
okay the hair lay it really a good idea
why don't you lumineer my frizziness who
invented not an [ __ ]
what am i bartender who - tabari worked
up I guess I should need to be feminist
Christ the demands of these pink out his
[ __ ] teeth man
this look is like in Kylie Kathy Kathy
that is a question that will haunt me
that's okay I'll being stupid okay